[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bon comment ça marche j'espère que vous
allez bien gagner je vous emmène au
soleil on est au soleil on est à Hawaii
on est sur la jolie île de Maui je vais
me faire arroser je me suis mis dans un
super cool sur les rochers pour qu'on en
profite je suis là pour vous montrer les
nouveaux processeurs de Qualcomm à
Hawaii ça s'ajoute c'est une autre vidéo
mais aujourd'hui je vais vous parler des
bons plans pour la fin de l'année alors
je sais que la le décorum fait pas trop
fin d'année fait pas trop Noël fais pas
trop Black Friday pour autant voyez là
tout de suite je suis en train de
tourner on est le 17 novembre je fais un
temps absolument incroyable et je me
suis dit pourquoi pas se faire rêver
dans un lieu totalement dingue vraiment
je suis très très près des rochers je
vous montre la regarder je suis sur les
rochers je suis juste là c'est à dire
que arrive un moment je risque de me
prendre une vague sur la gueule c'est un
peu mouillé là donc à tout moment à tout
moment je peux être trempé mais voilà ça
fera le charme de cette vidéo donc j'ai
sélectionné pas mal de produits que dont
je vais vous parler justement pour la
fin de l'année alors c'est vraiment une
sélection de produits que j'ai testé des
produits que j'ai vu tout au long de
l'année des produits qui m'ont marqué
qui m'ont intéressé et je me suis dit
que c'est peut-être des produits qui
pourraient vous plaire vous aussi donc
extrêmement gaffe c'est direction et
j'espère que ça vous plaira d'ailleurs
dites le moi dans les commentaires allez
on y va
[Applaudissements]
on va commencer par les smartphones
alors dans les smartphones ce qui m'a
bien plus cette année c'est déjà les
formats un peu différents c'est ce qu'on
avait vu l'année dernière du côté de
chez Samsung avec le zflip 3 ils ont
continué avec le zflu 4 alors que ce
soit l'un ou l'autre les deux sont très
bien le cadre sera un peu plus actuel on
reste sur le même format même s'il y a
quelques petites modifications donc ce
zip 4 je trouve vraiment vraiment
intéressant parce que ça reste un super
smartphone il est hyper canon il se plie
très bien il fait de superbe photo le
zflip 4 plus que les explique 3 parce
que les capteurs sont mieux on a un
processeur plus récent c'est vraiment un
smartphone que je peux vous recommander
pour le Black Friday pour la fin de
l'année c'est je pense un des
smartphones à avoir parce que vous avez
trouvé un tarif extrêmement intéressant
alors hot smartphone qui m'a beaucoup
plu c'est pas passé loin c'est plus un
smartphone du début d'année c'est le
oppo c'est le finding 5 Pro pourquoi
parce que même si c'est un smartphone
qui est du début de l'année parce que
j'ai vachement aimé avec ce smartphone
au-delà de la puce Dary siliconics
au-delà de tout ça ce qui m'a vachement
plus c'est le rendu des photos des
douceurs on a l'impression de shooter
avec un boîtier je trouve ça extrêmement
calié regardez les choses qui sont pas
dingues il y a des choses que je
reprocherai à ce smartphone mais si on
veut vraiment faire de très belles
photos et se rapprocher du côté photo
avec un boîtier la douceur de l'image
c'est vraiment un smartphone que j'ai
recommandé et que j'aime énormément donc
il faut vraiment venir le voir après le
smartphone que j'ai trouvé très
intéressant qui m'a beaucoup bluffé
c'est le Magic 4 pro de Honor on reste
toujours dans le haut du panier dans le
très haut de gamme mais il est super
performant il est vachement bien il fait
de superbes photos alors on aura pas la
même douceur qu'avec le fan de 5 Pro
mais si on veut un truc très polyvalent
très bon et très performant j'aime
beaucoup et je trouve que là-dessus au
nord a vraiment vraiment bien bossé qui
est aussi très cool c'est du côté de
chez Apple avec l'iPhone 14 pro 14 pro
max comment aurait pas le 14 parce que
là il a fait une 14 a 13 avec juste deux
cœurs GPU en plus on dirait que ça sert
globalement rien elle est vraiment sur
le 14 pro que j'ai beaucoup moi
j'utilise des iPhone 14 pro max que je
trouve très cool donc c'est aussi des
choses que peuvent venir recommander
après si on va aller sur les smartphones
un peu moins cher ce que j'aime bien
aussi c'est le Xiaomi 12 et pro que j'ai
beaucoup aimé que je peux venir vous
recommander le remis j'étais de pro qui
est très bien si on veut beaucoup de
performances on sera un peu moins bon en
photo mais par contre pour la
performance pour euh je veux dire le
musée pour faire du gaming qui a passé
le calcul c'est un super smartphone qui
est très très cool un autre smartphone
on retourne dans le haut du panier c'est
le Google pixelset alors il y a le set
le 7 pro mais je vais plutôt vous
recommander le pixel 7 parce que le
tarif est beaucoup plus maîtrisé et avec
des offres de fin d'année ça va être
encore plus canon c'est un super
smartphone vous avez pas le téléobjectif
que vous avez sur le pro mais par contre
vous avez de la photographie
computationnelle si Google derrière ça
marche bien c'est juste une vraie petite
bombe ça y est je viens de me faire
photo bomber enfin bombé tout simplement
arroser bombé par les vagues ça c'est un
truc très cool autre truc qui vachement
canon qui est sorti cette année en
milieu d'année au mois de juin je crois
c'est le pixel 6a qui est aussi très
bien un tarif extrêmement maîtrisé qui
est très très cool donc pixel si ça il
est canon du côté de chez Samsung on a
la valeur sûre c'est le Galaxy a53 donc
si vous aimez les smartphones de Samsung
et vous voulez un budget un petit peu
plus maîtriser Samsung Galaxy a53 très
cool et chez Samsung on a un peu
l'entre-deux entre le haut de gamme et
le milieu de gamme c'est le s21f je vous
ai présenté plus sur le début de l'année
mais qui est aussi un smartphone que
j'ai beaucoup aimé et aussi un autre
smartphone coup de cœur là c'est plus
sur le design qui est plus dans le
milieu de gamme c'est le nothing phone
qui est un peu différent qui est un
parti pris j'aime bien écouter un peu
rétro futuriste que je trouve très très
cool nothing phone je vous tu as bien
voir le poco X4 GT qui est aussi pas mal
pour le gaming voilà voilà un peu puis
sur l'entrée de gamme on va voir le
redmi note 11 c'est pas mal de chez
Xiaomi et puis si vous voulez un truc de
gaming une brut un truc de fou vous
allez sur le Rockford 6 de Asus que j'ai
vraiment adoré pour la partie à gaming
et je trouve vraiment mais vraiment
génial ça c'est pour la partie
smartphone et d'ailleurs j'y pense vos
smartphones pensez réellement à venir
les protéger et donc on va faire un
petit clin d'œil à mon partenaire
rhinoshield qui vient ici sponsoriser
cette vidéo à l'occasion du Black Friday
rhinoshield vous permet d'avoir jusqu'à
moins 60% de remise sur tout le site et
avec le code gros 22 vous aurez 10 % de
remis supplémentaires je vous mets le
lien juste en bas dans la description le
Black Friday c'est le moment de venir
acheter vos produits tech elle est
arrivée beaucoup plus réduite que ce
soit votre smartphone que ce soit vos
airpods que ce soit votre APPLE Watch et
ça tombe bien parce que justement
rhinoshield a des protection pour tous
ces articles avec des remis je vous dis
une fois de plus qu'ils vont jusqu'à
moins 60% à l'occasion du Black Friday
alors parmi les réductions j'ai noté pas
mal de choses qui peuvent vous
intéresser vous avez - 15 % sur les
coques de l'iPhone 14 pro et du S22 - 25
% sur les coques des séries des iPhone
11 12 13 et sur les protections d'écran
moins 30% sur les coques de protection
des airpods pro à noter que leurs
accessoires sont compatibles avec plus
d'une centaine de modèles de smartphones
dont les nouveaux iPhone 14 et les
pixels 7 autant dire qu'ici vous avez
trouvé votre bonheur leur coque sont
ultra-résistante vous avez la clé qui
est une coque transparente et qui ne
jaunit pas la solitude pour une
protection maximale vous avez le grip
c'est une poignée pour le téléphone qui
permet d'avoir un super maintien et qui
fait office de support pour venir
regarder des vidéos ou pour venir se
prendre en photo ou se filmer mais leur
produit sont également totalement
personnalisables on peut même aller
jusqu'au bouton autant vous dire qu'ici
on peut aller super loin et dispo
également en version maxife alors il y a
plein de collections différentes on va
voir One Piece Naruto Star Wars la NASA
le Seigneur des Anneaux la NBA Game of
Thrones bref il y en a énormément et
n'oubliez pas également de venir
protéger vos écrans et vos objectifs
avec leur protection en verre trempé
autant vous dire qu'ici c'est le bon
moment pour venir changer vos produits
tech et également penser à venir les
protéger et merci à rhinoshield d'avoir
sponsorisé cette vidéo alors je vous ai
parlé smartphone mais il y a également
l'audio qui me plaît beaucoup j'ai
découvert il y a pas longtemps ce sont
les bosses qcbuts 2 sont juste
incroyables sont de super qualité
surtout une réduction de bruit qui est à
tomber par terre alors il vient de
sortir donc je sais pas si on trouvera
les réductions les plus folles mais une
fois de plus je mets les liens en bas
dans la description c'est un produit que
j'adore que je trouve vraiment mais
absolument incroyable et je dis beaucoup
incroyable mais vraiment je vous assure
je l'adore alors on dit je peux venir
vous recommander sont les airpods pro 2
également super qualité je dirais que
les bosses on va plus ça chez Android et
si on veut aller ici sur iOS on peut
venir se prendre c'est airpods 2 Pro
c'est un peu comme ça je vais voir les
choses alors un casque qui est sorti
cette année qui m'a beaucoup plu c'est
le Sony c'est le WH médical 5 alors la
différence du X-5 par rapport au xm4 xm3
c'est qu'il vient passe plier de la même
manière le format change un peu mais il
y a plein de nouveaux intérêts
intéressants toujours une super
réduction de bruit toujours en super
confort toujours en super casque une
super application ici signer Sony et que
personnellement j'adore et autre casque
alors il est pas nouveau il est pas
sorti d'hier ça fait deux ans qu'il est
sorti c'est le airpods max que j'utilise
tout le temps et croyez-moi en terme de
qualité en termes de restitution en
termes de plein de choses il est
incomparable très cher donc si on peut
le trouver un tarif beaucoup plus
maîtrisé à l'occasion de ces fêtes de
fin d'année et bien réellement ça vaut
le coup alors autre produit c'est les
montres bah les montres forcément on les
envoie au poignet ça fait partie de
l'écosystème d'objets connectés le
smartphone qui piloté avec la montre
pour la musique et si ça et puis les
écouteurs bien évidemment mais alors la
montre elle a une place de choix hyper
importante au niveau de l'écosystème et
là j'ai vu des montres qui m'ont
beaucoup plus année je vais sélectionner
je dirais deux principalement la galaxie
watch 5 watch 5 Pro j'ai trouvé hyper
canon du côté de chez Samsung pour tout
ce qui va être Android et puis du côté
de chez Apple bien évidemment l'Apple
watch Apple Watch et ceux qui je pense
aujourd'hui est le super compromis au
niveau des montres ça c'est super cool
vous avez également la Watch 8 si on
veut aller un peu plus loin je suis pas
convaincu que la ultra soit pour
monsieur et madame tout le monde donc
bon on n'aura pas forcément besoin mais
en tout cas pour moi la SOS c'est
vraiment le produit à avoir si on a un
iPhone alors qui parle de smartphone qui
parle de montre on va parler également
de tablette on va continuer chez Apple
alors moi un truc que j'ai bien aimé
cette année c'est alors déjà c'est très
très cher c'est l'iPad pro la version m2
je trouve super hyper canon elle marche
bien c'est une bête de performance elle
est vraiment top elle coûte très cher
bon peut-être la trouver un tarif un
petit peu plus maîtrisé sinon ce que je
peux vous conseiller c'est vraiment
d'aller sur l'iPad 10 qui est un super
iPad c'est une évolution se rapproche un
peu de l'iPad air un tarif un peu plus
élevé par rapport à ce qu'on avait à
l'iPad 9 l'année dernière mais le design
était revue était amélioré était corrigé
donc si trouver un tarif un petit peu
plus bas franchement c'est un produit
qui vaut vraiment le coup alors du côté
de chez Samsung où est-ce que j'ai
beaucoup aimé aussi cette année c'est
assez cher en tarif c'est la galaxie Tab
S8 ultra alors il y a eu la S8 plus à la
suite ultra si vous trouvez là est-ce
que tu le feras un tarif un peu plus bas
franchement foncé elle est géniale grand
écran hyper confort beaucoup de
performances et vous prenez en plus
d'accessoires qui vont avec franchement
vous ferez vraiment plaisir alors il y a
les PC aussi c'est pas mal de PC
notamment du côté de chez Huawei
matebook 16s MacBook D16 qui sont canon
si vous voulez me faire plaisir pour
nous très très jolies PC ça marche très
bien il y a aussi le Galaxy book 2 ça me
saoule que j'ai trouvé vraiment
intéressant assez léger emmené partout
avec soi et plein de fonctionnalités
très très cool et alors si on veut se
faire un petit kiffe c'est le Asus c'est
le Zenbook pro 14 duo OLED je vous l'ai
présenté également en vidéo c'est très
particulier comme produit vous avez un
grand écran un autre écran en bas on
peut venir faire pas mal de choses
j'adore je le trouve personnellement
extrêmement canon donc si vous arrivez à
trouver un tarif un peu plus maîtrisé ça
vaut vraiment le coup alors il y a un
autre sujet qui est aussi très important
c'est toute la question de la maison
connectée je sais pas si vous avez une
maison connectée mais vraiment je vous
recommande d'aller trouver les bons
produits pour la maison connectée alors
moi j'utilise beaucoup les produits de
Google à la la maison j'ai un coup gagne
Houston Max qui ne servira de cadre
photo qui me servira également pour voir
qu'encore quelqu'un vient sonner chez
moi sur ma Google nesdor ça c'est
vachement bien c'est ma sonnette à la
porte d'entrée qui me sert en plus de ça
de système de surveillance à la maison
ça c'est quand même vachement cool
lorsque vous absentez là vous avez des
images directement en plus de ça alors
moi j'ai pris un petit abonnement chez
Google je vais tout stocker dans le
Cloud comme ça je vais quand même
vachement loin en terme de oh la vache
il fallait que ça arrive c'est pas grave
c'est quand même vachement cool je vais
vraiment vous recommander tous ces
produits Google que j'aime bien alors
après c'est vous préférez il y a aussi
d'autres produits très cool du côté de
chez Amazon alors Amazon moi j'utilise
une fire TV que je trouve très très
sympa si vous avez une télé qui est un
petit peu ancienne par exemple si c'est
pas une Smart TV ou si vous avez une
Smart TV mais que vous aimez pas
l'expérience et bien vous pouvez venir à
prendre une fire TV qui sera très très
cool ici que j'ai vraiment vous
recommander et puis pour venir sécuriser
votre maison j'ai testé il y a pas
longtemps les caméras de Arlo de
surveillance il y en a différentes je
vous renvoie à ma vidéo c'est très canon
et ça marche bien alors puisque dans la
maison il y a aussi d'autres choses que
je veux vraiment vous recommander mais
plus plus plus j'en parle énormément
c'est tout ce qui va être Philips you
c'est à dire les éclairages connectés
j'adore le système de Philips you ils
ont une vraie profondeur de gamme au
niveau des cool au niveau des lampes au
niveau de plein de choses et moi j'ai
connecté toute la maison en Philips you
ce qui me permet de tout venir piloter à
distance si vous êtes absent vous pouvez
faire de la présence artificielle ça
c'est vachement bien en plus de votre
système de surveillance à la maison vous
êtes très très cool donc je viens
vraiment vous le recommander je suis un
très gros amoureux des produits de
Philippe soude vraiment vous pouvez y
aller les yeux fermés il y a des kits de
démarrage avec un pont et des ampoules
ça coûte une petite blindes donc si vous
pouvez le trouver un tarif beaucoup plus
maîtrisé commencer par acheter le kit de
démarrage avec le pont et les deux
ampoules et le petit interrupteur
connecté vous allez voir franchement une
fois qu'on a mis le pied dedans on
dépense des fortunes parce que c'est
juste hyper canon donc profitez-en à
l'occasion des fêtes de fin d'année
alors un autre truc est très cool en
terme de décoration c'est les nanoleaf
nanolea les canvas il y a les moi j'ai
testé les lines s'il y a pas longtemps
je vous recommande plus plus d'aller sur
les lines je trouve super cool en terme
de décoration on n'en met pas des
caisses en mettant en temps il y a
souligner un peu la déco ça a vraiment
vraiment très très jolie et une fois de
plus je vais vous le recommander
totalement alors après il y a un autre
accessoire à la maison qui est très cool
sont les aspirateurs connectés alors
j'en ai testé plein je testais du robot
rock c'était les covacs c'était du Dream
le dernier que j'ai testé j'ai beaucoup
aimé c'est le Dream mebot L17 ultra le
nom est un peu rallonge mais je vous
mets le lien dans la description le
produit est juste hyper cool pourquoi
pourquoi parce qu'il fait tout il vient
aspirer il vient nettoyer une fois qu'il
a fini il vient nettoyer ses petites
brosses des brosses propres la maison
est toujours hyper clean il vient les
sécher à la fin pour éviter les odeurs
de moisissures dans la brosse il a un
liquide de nettoyage qui est inclus il a
un bac d'eau propre il vous renvoie tout
sur le bac de salle bref tout ça
vraiment très très malin et en plus un
petit bac de récupération de vos
poussières enfin bref ça a vraiment
vraiment cool après il y en a plein
d'autres c'est beaucoup aimé les choses
il y a aussi des produits qui sont
intéressants très haut de gamme sur
bureau qui est là c'est toi qui sont un
peu le milieu de gamme qui sont très
cool et que je vais une fois de plus
venir vous recommander donc l'aspirateur
connecté pour la maison c'est pas un
gadget c'est comme moi vous détestez
faire le ménage et bien vous le laissez
bosser il va faire 90% du taf et vous
vous venez de temps en temps récupérer
la Wii peut pas passer et ce qui est
quand même vachement cool alors après
j'ai d'autres produits que j'ai beaucoup
aimé cette année alors là c'est un peu
plus pour les créateurs de contenu comme
moi une caméra alors je sais pas on a
tous ordinateurs et on vient tous faire
de la conférence on l'a vu avec le covid
on vient se connecter à distance il y a
une caméra que j'ai adoré c'est
l'instinct 360 link je vous renvoie à ma
vidéo c'est une petite bombe elle est
géniale elle a plein de super
fonctionnalités la qualité dingue elle a
un tracking enfin bref elle est vraiment
vraiment cool je ne peux que vous leur
si vous filmez avec votre smartphone
vous êtes créateur de contenu je vous
recommande lorsque Mobile 6 avec plein
de nouvelles fonctionnalités pour faire
des effets stabiliser ces jeunes faire
arroser c'est vraiment génial et puis ce
que j'utilise tout de suite ça c'est le
dji Mike le dji Mike il est génial parce
que là j'utilise l'émission mon boîtier
il est juste au dessus vous venez le
brochet directement sur un smartphone il
y a tous les embouts directement
usb-c Lightning vous avez directement
deux petits émetteurs ici avec les
petites bonnettes anti-vent vous avez le
récepteur qui est très cool vous pouvez
venir enregistrer un petit backup ici à
moi si décibels directement sur votre
émetteur c'est vachement rassurant bref
c'est vraiment un produit à avoir et que
je recommande plus plus à tous les
créateurs de contenus moi j'avais des
robes avant je switché je suis parti
là-dessus vraiment je le regrette
absolument pas alors voilà pour cette
petite sélection c'est vraiment une
sélection au non exhaustive il y a plein
d'autres produits que j'ai beaucoup aimé
mais moi faut venir faire des choix là
la vidéo est un peu longue mais voilà
c'est vraiment la sélection de choses
qui m'ont marqué il y a plein d'autres
produits ne vous offusquez pas si j'ai
pas parlé de plein d'autres produits que
j'ai beaucoup aimé mais voilà il fallait
faire des choix sont les choix que
j’arbitré et que voilà je sais pas si
vous vous avez acheté un de ces produits
cette année en 2022 s'il pourrait vous
tenter en tout cas c'est ma sélection
pour les fêtes de fin d'année Black
Friday Noël donc profitez-en et une fois
de plus je vous mets tous les liens en
bas dans la description allez jeter un
coup d'oeil pour venir acheter vos
produits dans les meilleures conditions
et ça c'est vachement bien et on finit
regardez juste là avec la petite vue
voilà histoire que on se fasse plaisir
regardez ça Hawaii il fait super beau je
vais une fois de plus me faire toucher
par la flotte donc je vous envoie une
petite dose d'inspiration respirer on
prend un bon bol d'air chaud un bon bol
d'air marin ici et puis ressourcez-vous
parce que je sais qu'il fait pas très
très chaud ailleurs c'est normal c'est
l'hiver voilà donc je vous embrasse
prenez soin de vous et à très bientôt
pour continuer bien évidemment à parler
tech beaucoup d'amour à bientôt Ciao
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]